(suspenseful music)
(animal whistling)
[Narrator] On June 16th
[Vocalizing the Friday the 13th
theme]
[Morgan] Baby, stop playin'!
[Shawn] Wait, hold up.
I know I left this door open.
[Narrator] See the
horror film
preview audiences are calling
a killer experience.
[Lisa] The Blackening.
(creature roaring)
[Dewayne] No, no thank you.
[King] Probably runs
on racism.
[The Killer] Pick a card.
(suspenseful music)
Or you die.
- In your predicament,
the Black character is
always the first to die.
I will spare your lives if
you sacrifice the person
you deem the Blackest.
[Clifton] Guys, I can prove
I'm not the Blackest.
[Shanika] Prove it.
- I thought Black Twitter
was a type of seasoning.
I like Jimmy Fallon
without The Roots?
- Eh! Wrong.
- I voted for Trump.
(suspenseful music)
(audience gasping)
- What?
- Twice.
- You--
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
(bell dings)
- Your time is up.
It's time to die.
(dart whistling)
(dart thumping)
(audience screaming)
♪ Let's go ♪
(electronic music)
- [Allison] What do we do?
- Call the cops?
(all laughing)
(killer growling)
(audience screaming)
♪ Shots, shots ♪
- We need a plan.
- Let's get some weapons!
♪ Shots, shots, shots, shots ♪
- Wait. Chili powder?
Girl, what I finna do, cook?
- Sorry, girl, we ran
out of knives.
♪ Everybody ♪
(gunshot firing)
(person laughing)
♪ Everybody ♪
(killer laughing)
(audience screaming)
- Why Black women gotta save
everyone all the damn time?!
- Oh, man.
- Woo.
♪ Shots, shots, shots,
shots, shots, shots ♪
(electronic music)
- Can we just go?
[Ranger White] Lock the
doors, get down.
I'll be right back.
[Audience] Boo!
(electronic music)